Speaker 1: I don't want to spend a ton of
time on this, but so many of you emailed me
about it that I do want to say a little bit
about it yet.
Two days ago, the Florida Republican Gov.
Ron DeSantis appeared with some high schoolers
and behaved in a just disgusting manner.
He went over to them, and he told them, almost
like in a bullying way, take the masks off.
Check this out.
Speaker 4: You do not have to wear those masks.
I mean, please think honestly, it's not doing
anything, and we got to stop with this coded
fear.
So you want to wear fine, but this is a this
is ridiculous.
All right.
Well, it's good to be at USF now.
Speaker 1: So I mean, like, listen, first
of all, what a leader, right?
We're not against masks.
We just don't think the government should
be telling you to wear them.
But I'm going to tell you not to wear them
and I'm here from the government.
Come on, dude.
And when you look at this guy, I understand
why 28 percent of C-PAC wants this guy to
be the Republican nominee because he's sort
of like a more aggressive, more competent,
more dangerous version of Trump.
This guy is Trump, but slightly less nuts
in the way of being cartoonish but very, very
dangerous.
Now, one kid decided to keep the mask on,
and some people are saying, Oh wow, what a
hero, whatever.
What's wild is, this is not even the craziest
part of DeSantis is very, very strange appearance
at in Florida, this workforce education event.
He also bizarrely attacked France kind of
playing up this story that France is is basically
weak and sissy.
Like, we're still doing these stupid tropes.
Yeah.
Ron DeSantis is doing them
Speaker 4: a lot of other places around the
world.
They just fold the minute.
There's any type of adversity.
I mean, can you imagine if he went into France,
would they do anything to put up a fight?
Probably not.
And so those folks, you know, are stepping
up, but it's a there's a lot of problems,
I think, between now and then.
And I think unfortunately, it's going to end
up very, very ugly.
Speaker 1: I mean, guys, this is a governor
whose analysis of the Russian invasion of
Ukraine is the people in Ukraine are actually
doing something they're trying to resist,
whereas sissy French people wouldn't do anything.
I mean, these are some of the most basic course
tropes that have been floating around for
20 years.
Remember John Kerry back when he ran against
George W. Bush for president in 2000?
For the whole idea, because Kerry speaks French,
the whole thing was.
Kerry is a sissy because he speaks French.
These are such dumb tropes, and they still
exist with people like DeSantis and the people
that follow the Sanders.
Here's one last clip.
And here's DeSantis asked, Did you agree with
anything?
Joe Biden said in his State of the Union.
And he kind of hems and haws and gives a very
weird answer.
Speaker 2: Would you consider it unanimously
positive for certain points of view?
Speaker 4: You disagree with the Earth?
You know, I mean, I think I have to think
about some of the stuff.
Well, I mean, I agree.
You know, if you think about what they've
done, Fauci is in the witness protection program
now.
They don't want him out there.
No, they they've never supported any of you.
Speaker 1: If you listen.
So I guess what the Sanders is saying, it's
a very backhanded compliment.
He seems to be saying the aspect of the State
of the Union address that I agreed agreed
with is that Biden didn't mention Fauci and
Fauci wasn't there.
I guess.
I mean, it's a really backhanded compliment.
It's really not a compliment to them.
Speaker 4: They never supported all these
policies that were so destructive.
Now it's like, you know, we all want to be
like Florida all of a sudden, and nothing
has changed.
Speaker 1: Of course, many, many, many things
have changed.
When you look at case numbers, when you look
at immunity, it's not even worth it.
OK.
The takeaway here is the Santas bullying children
into taking off their masks vile.
But everything he said at this event reminds
me of how Trump was really, really bad.
If this guy is actually the nominee and potentially
becomes the next president of the United States,
it will be worse than with Trump.
This guy is just as wacky, but he's more competent
and more able to do all of the horrible things
that he would try to do.
Let's hope it does.
I'm not saying I'd rather Trump be president.
It's a crazy thing to say, but in some way
it might be less bad if Trump were President
Trump at nearly 80 more incompetent and even
presumably lower energy just as a result of
his age seems less dangerous than Ron DeSantis
as president of the United States.
It's my view as of today.
If you agree, disagree.
Either way, let me know what you think Trump
or DeSantis, if you knew one of them, would
be the next president.
Let me know on Twitter where you can find
me at Packman.
The David Pakman show is, after all, a viewer
supported program, a listener supported program,
and I would encourage you to get a membership
at join Packman dot com.
It's cheap, it's quick, it's easy.
You'll get access to the world famous bonus
show every day.
You'll also get a commercial free audio and
video feed of the show every day, six hours
before everybody else.
Why wait?
Get the show early by signing up at Join Packman
dot com!